I dated a professional athlete great at
what he does there's not a lot of room
for emotion to be involved it's either
true or it's not true or you're going to
get your neck broken he could date
whoever he wanted or sleep with whoever
you wanted and we were like arguing
about something and I was like well why
would you date me if like I'm the person
you date if you want like a challenge
and he just went why would any man want
a challenge in their relationship in
that moment was like oh my God I thought
it was like hot to you I thought it was
like what guys wanted I thought it was
like feisty like I apologize well
especially if you're dating somebody
that is high performing in any realm has
goals if you're working that hard in the
office you really want to come home and
be like right there's that to-do list
done I wonder what fires I need to fight
when I step through the front door as
well